what's the relationship between
computational irreducibility and
undecidability general undecidability
so
also the relationship between the
reducibility and the principle of
computational equivalence does one
require the other can you imagine a
world with one but not the other
so principle of computational
equivalence implies computational
releasability
and and basically they're really locked
together because what happens is
you have a system it's computing what
it's going to do next
you are an observer of that system
you're trying to predict what it's going
to do next
the question is can you jump ahead of it
and figure out what it's going to do
sort of more efficiently than it does
itself
principle of computational equivalence
says
you sorry you're stuck being just
computationally equivalent to the system
and that's what leads to computational
irreducibility
undecidability is an infinite time limit
of computational irreducibility
computational irreducibility
is
a if you say what's the system going to
do in the end after an infinite amount
of time
the answer
uh can be
well in order if it's computationally
irreducible the only way to find that
out is to wait for a potentially
infinite amount of time so if you say i
really want to know in finite time
what's the system going to do the answer
is sorry it's computationally
irreducible the only way to know that
infinite time answer is to wait an
infinite time
so that that's the reason that um so
those uh you know computational
irreducibility implies undecidability
could undecidability exist
i don't think so i think it might be
associated with some things called
intermediate degrees which are an idea
that you can have a system which has
undecidability without computational
universality which i tend to think is is
not really it's not a real thing it's a
it's something people imagine can happen
in systems but i don't think it will
actually end up happening it's something
where you can construct examples which
are kind of special put up jobs where
you essentially have a universal
computer inside but you've chopped off
all its input output mechanisms enough
that it can't act as a universal
computer but can still have
undersidability and i don't think that's
a i don't think that's a real real thing
but um uh yeah so so those are
undecidability is infinite time limits
of irreducibility basically